don't delay with that update because
there are a few good reasons to download
iOS 9.3 first there's night shift it
adjusts the brightness and color
temperature of the display depending on
what time of day it is the idea is that
these color schemes work a lot better
with your circadian rhythms so it should
make it a lot easier for you to fall
asleep the best part is that you don't
have to do anything night shift user's
location services and the clock on your
device to determine when the Sun Goes
Down the second reason to update your
phone more privacy for the Notes app if
you use notes to store sensitive stuff
like passwords you can now protect those
notes with touch ID and lastly for those
with the iphone 6s or 6s plus you can
now put your fingers to work with 3d
touch tap and hold on the Settings app
icon you'll see a quick action menu for
Wi-Fi Bluetooth and battery menus it
works on the App Store icon to try this
press and hold on the icon to see a
shortcut that updates all of your apps
with one tap more apps will be able to
incorporate touch 3d in the future so be
on the lookout for those updates